approaching eight minutes to go in the
fourth still plenty of time in this game
that's still with work to do
as james harden with the love to play
griffin as he stares down to pistons
bench
and blake griffin that was he get it up
and throw it down but he is yelling at
the bench
tension horizon between these two teams
just over two minutes gone by here in
the fourth
they handle the press lob it up blake
griffin
air griffin 220 remaining in this fourth
quarter
kyrie irving almost a turnover good ball
movement
pelicans close out well griffin left
open now griffin goes to the hole
and elevates for the two-handed jam 24
points
six rebounds six assists for the
underrated chris middleton
durant for three oh
blake griffin with the left-handed slam
blake griffin attacking the offensive
boards
big-time finish with a little contact
he's played extremely well for the nets
[Applause]
my goodness 20 fast break points
for the spurs already
griffin gets the step oh blake griffin
the smash
[Applause]
three point shots some yams
blake griffin one of those i think he
was looking for a foul here
not sure that but what we can see is the
bench all off their feet
alize johnson almost running on the
court
oh yeah uncle jeff your boy could do it
too
all of the shots here have been tough
for boston because of this defense
almost like
brooklyn looked disinterested on defense
during the regular season but now
oh boy griffin hears it from the crowd
a vicious dunk by griffin unselfish play
harden give-and-go action finds blake
griffin
and able to finish with authority talk
about a resurgence in his play
has had some strong performances you
talk about deandre hunter has not played
in this series great ball movement and
finishes blake griffin
once again with the left hand
using the round great cut by harris
beautiful pass griffin
i think with a stretch this year where
he didn't have a dunk
prior to arriving in brooklyn almost
seven foot westbrook particularly when
he has the ball
in the open court similarities in
three-point shooting also
oh
[Applause]
basketball fans in detroit who saw blake
griffin for what three and a half
seasons asking
where did this come from